hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the try not to smile
challenge now I know some of you have
probably seen these videos before but
there is a subreddit called
are made me smile that does nothing but
compile these videos that are only there
to warm the dark cold stone hearts that
we all have in our chests and hopefully
when I'm watching these videos I'll just
remember all of the deathly sour
memories and like horrible voices inside
my head and will not be happy or smile
at any of these videos that we're about
to see now that's the challenge I don't
think I'm gonna win it because I'm a
joyous baby at heart inside my body is a
baby no I'm not pregnant that's not
right inside it's inside somewhere in me
there's a smiling baby that's just so
giggly this is a giggly little [ __ ]
inside of me and alright this is getting
weird this analogy is weird I'm a giggly
[ __ ] and that includes seeing things
like these videos that you're about to
see that are happy and fun and free and
are gonna be great so we're gonna get to
that right now you ready I'm ready
I'm not ready this one's called dog
tries to stop stream the water
don't smile if you smile I will come
over to your house and beat the [ __ ] out
of you and then hug you because you're
obviously trying to be happy so much
anyway whatever
[Music]
that's not cute
[Music]
that's not cute that is not cute that's
not cute up up oh okay
alright alright the charm is worn off
obviously that dog Oh can't stop that
whole river
oh but goddamn it he's gonna try oh god
this is the most impossible challenge
I've ever had in my life oh it's so good
what is that what is that hmm that's the
face that's the same thing Maggie does
when she doesn't want to take a bath hmm
this is gonna be nothing but animals
being cute and adorable Oh such a pup oh
that was such a good pup Oh goddamn it's
another dog oh I'm gonna cry oh I'm
gonna cry
see this would be the try not to cry oh
[Laughter]
oh no good pop oh she looks like chica
so much oh god where's chica I need to
hug chica I got a I got a hug chica like
right now please take I need you to help
me finish this video let's go oh oh no
oh no chica
come on Oh pop Oh Oh pop oh oh oh oh my
god
Oh frickin dick oh [ __ ] this challenge
okay I just donated a thousand dollars
to hope for pause because my god
that video was amazing and just oh my
god I love you
we're only like what is this like three
videos in and my god I've already
destroyed the challenge
[Music]
now it's not cute to him it's just
nothing but dogs I am a heartless
bastard I will not smile at this
adorable Ness in fact it's not durable
at all
[Music]
it's not cute not in any way oh look at
his little stump arms though oh no thank
you
not cute not cute at all not adorable oh
they broke it didn't break it
map map map map map okay that's good hey
[Music]
what is that what is that it's a baby
ostrich no I've never seen one before
oh no they're so cute oh my god they're
so tiny they'll grow up to be so
monstrous is that a baby
youmu I don't want to subscribe to watch
them grow ah I want them to stay that
forever Oh stay oh no this is the
greatest subreddit that anyone has ever
ever done no no that was cute it's two
grown men being cute and adorable no all
right so this didn't go well
I uh I failed I feel bad I failed hard
and yeah I have no remorse for it those
friggin adorable that subreddit is so
cool I'll try to link every video that I
I saw here in the description and also
I'll link to the subreddit it's just
chock full of that stuff so if you need
a smile today if you need to be a little
happy go to that sub Rhett and plow
through all the videos there they're all
amazing so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought of this one I think it's a I
think it's a nice change from the
horrible videos that I have to
through just to get to the fun he
wouldn't I mean but either way it's
pretty cool and I like it a lot Oh God
touches my heart anyway so thank you
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye